on va vous faire un petit quizz c'est
les frérots des stars c'est très simple
je vous montre une star et vous me dites
est celle au frère de qui d'accord
attention bien que ça c'est le frère de
qui par exemple regarder
1re c'est parti merci origine
[Musique]
ça c'est le frère de qui ça oui on
dirait c'est le frère de qui ça a dit
rami c'est le frère de m matt pokora
c'est julien tota le grand frère de matt
pokora est franchement faut ou pas c'est
jérémy toujours oui attend sa nouvelle
super nul si tu t'es nul tu peux
demander mieux ils ont que ça à faire
attention regarde prochain frère ça
c'est le frère de qui ça ah oui ce
serait à lui manuel macro oui bravo
c'est le frère d'emmanuel macro bravo
mais ouais c'est laurent macron le petit
frère d'emmanuel mâcon il est médecin
il est spécialisé en réel en radiologie
du coeur mais il rentre en plus à
sarkozy je trouve et vous vous allez
fêter vos l'ophtalmo record alors
attention troisième ça c'est des beaux
arts si bon vivre ici c'est non et le
parti frère jérémy pas c'est pas du tout
c'est leur univers
[Rires]
mais laure manaudou le petit frère
d'omar exactement bbc il a 19 ans et
mannequin on embrasse un effort omar et
son frère attention là c'est qui ça moi
aussi réussi à s'extraire de ramzi
n'ont-ils frère de ramzi pas du tout pas
du tout c'est le frère d'un humoriste
l'attention à l'humoriste memory un
humoriste que j'aime beaucoup
à altra n'auriez pas n'annoncez pas que
c'est un action couper ça c'est le frère
c'est le petit frère d'une chanteuse aux
malades qui n'ont amel bent nom gilbert
non c'est pas shy'm qui va venir
l'instant c'est ça que j'ai d'ailleurs
elle a fait l a fait elle a fait la star
ac c'est le petit frère ami de jennifer
je n'attends bartoli qui lui ressemble
mais très bohême et c'est le petit frère
de jennifer il est aussi chanteur
attention là c'est une sur epte
attention serez mes témoins la soeurette
allez-y allez-y c'est qu'ils savent
vincent mcdoom non
[Rires]
sortez la soeur de kylie compliqué mais
non mais non là là non non michelle
obama
non c'est gérard jugnot je ne sais
jamais quoi un mec c'est le pied c'est
la soeur de quelqu'un d'un chanteur sait
que c'est un chanteur un chandail noir
yannick noah bravo raymond d'affaires
allez c'est parti ça s'écrit salle train
de qui madame ce qu'on a battu laver ou
pas tu allais dire complètement autre
chose toi non d'accord c'est bien
vigueur le 1er mai lors du replay on va
on va mettre attention des beaux mecs là
bas on va mettre une valse d'adaptation
on a en garde prochain le prévenu est
cité au qu'on embrasse fort aussi les
créateurs de mode et j'embrasse antoine
qui fera son dernier match à madrid ni
midi ou 12 mai enfin la gaude madrid
après je sais pas s'il va partir ou pas
donc là à dire que tu sais que tu sais
dernier match de la saison je sais rien
je vous laisserai à nos noms je sais pas
si j'y serai opca cpsia mais se sait pas
si ce sera son directeur
il va rester à l'atlético je pense façon
et il est bon partout dans le monde et
je pense que c'est très bien attention
pour la dernière c'est très dur
je vous le dis celui qui trouve pour la
nappe
[Rires]
là furent alors qu'ils écrivent ko
griche d'accord c'est lui je le voulais
toujours dit english à celui qui a le
menton comme à l'eau qu'il a le menton
bus comme as l'auteur trace à toblerone
et autres 100000 toblerone messie on le
sait on le sait on le sait